what's up guys so I'm currently in San
Francisco I've been doing some research
there places to eat and food around here
and I stumbled upon this place called
Donny poquito now this technically isn't
a restaurant
they've got shops all over the city and
they specialize in serving insects and
bugs now I don't know much about the bug
and insect industry they say on their
website that it's got a lot of protein
it's better for the environment that's
pretty much all I know so I'm gonna go
to the kitchen and I'm gonna learn more
about this business I'm gonna actually
try the insects and their products and
I'm gonna bring my friend Ibrahim
Renault who studies a lot of diets he
knows a lot about food and nutrition so
let's go try some bugs when I was in
Thailand it's the only thing I didn't
try it this is my first time ever like
flying this what this food eats which is
very important because whatever in this
food system you're gonna eat it it's
gonna mean your system I don't know what
they eat I don't know like that's the
thing my only concern does like you know
because we as you know we have a show 8
p.m. yeah so I was like are you sure if
we eat this we gonna be fine
I'm gonna be like you know where's Erik
and Ibraheem oh they're just they eat
like insects for lunch and they cannot
show up for like the show kitchen town
is where the bugs are made yeah a little
bit about cooking town we're just like a
low overhead industrial kitchen so
people that want to get on their feet
running about how many businesses are in
the kitchen right now I think it's like
30 years old it's like a communal
kitchen that businesses that don't have
enough money yet can pay less for this
kitchen and like all use it together and
get their start here and whatever sells
well can then go to markets and then
once they get enough money they can
start their own business get their own
kitchen so it's almost like a startup
kitchen support the people who's flying
best to provide for you a clean healthy
food what is it this guy from Nepal who
invented these Sherpa inspired energy
bus that the ingredients are basically
the ingredients that the Sherpas beat to
climb up Mount Everest in Malaysia these
are almonds from Persia and mulberries
recursion right that's I know and I
didn't either until I saw this
biochemist from Spain and he went into
the orange orange juice some
complementary pastries with rhubarb name
a gluten-free banana killer croissant in
chocolate were almond the almond paste
and then a couple cinnamon and this is
all made in this kitchen that early
morning a bakery life let's try it
you
so this is the kitchen a kitchen down
WTO is an area inside your business we
beam and the market for a couple years
we were one of the businesses you cannot
open the dialog aware of our insights
and United States they spiritual
Kentucky comes directly from my own
culture like I grew up in Mexico and
Mexico a believer some edible insect TV
and we have over 500 biographies of
edible insects in Mexico 80% of the
world eats insects
except United States and Europe all that
so interesting yeah 80% of the biomass
on the planet is made by insects so
doesn't make any sense and even insects
yeah like crazy on animals so the entire
American continent didn't have cattle
chickens of pork before Europeans came
to America right so we've been selling
of these animals that were non-native of
the American continent sitting on these
ecosystems for them to thrive but at the
same time with including contaminating
cutting forests and order of creating
this protein what are the missing things
about
no system meaning they're very water
efficient if everybody would indeed
insects at least one day and I mean any
toilet alleyway and amazing we had a
great impact so they produce more
protein with less amount of food but
damages it is and they also the amount
of space so we can you know form three
to four times more than mono campaign
and watches more space so United States
actually has been funded insects to be
chickens English so you do need chicken
so then I was like well why don't we
have a picture chicken insects are like
genetically far removed from humans
genetics so they make it make them such
a great who died because there's less
cross-contamination like it's really
harder for us to get like bird flu of
mad cow disease from an insect these are
very similar
and there was a very similar in flavor
so these guys they taste like corner
Wars right yeah these are like new ones
they're not really wanted larva so these
guys it tastes like almonds and then we
make them like that caramelized talking
oh my god they're amazing flavor so
these are literally just toasted
crickets
we have like the Omega 3 the gup-x mode
with mine and it's like this
got a good spice like it doesn't make
you nauseous spicy but it just feels
like it's like I think I learned today
that worms aren't look I thought if I
have to coordinate late
it's so good just like clockwork but
these are jokes when it correctly gets
why with Ameren it's so good you are
incredible high five it's amazing I
never budge and yeah I'm going to take
this home for me it was like a bunch of
jumping Spears I was like I'm gonna put
on anything I got I could get it my
mouth and swallow I was actually
concerned but actually is really tasty
is very good and what she explained was
really like made so much sense
I'm so glad like you know I'm so thank
you for the Don Benito kitchen down good
job
if you guys are ever in SF or go online
check it out so yes for me
[Music]